good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack Van
Horn from the University of Virginia and I'm
very proud to welcome you to this edition of
our 2022-2023 foundations of biomedical data
science seminar series the seminar series is
supported by uva's integrated translational
Health Institute of Virginia the UVA brain
Institute the College of Arts and Sciences
the school of data science and through a grants
from the National Institutes of General Medical
Sciences since 2016 the foundations of biomedical
data science seminar Series has focused on the
use of data science methodologies artificial
intelligence deep learning and statistical
modeling as they pertain to differing themes
in the biomedical and Health Sciences this
year's theme is data science and the public
health consequences of the covid-19 pandemic
where we will enjoy presentations on Friday
afternoons from leading thinkers about the
issues the promise opportunities and hurdles
associated with understanding the secondary
health effects of the covid-19 virus these
include delayed Health checkups treatments
mental health drug abuse policy implications
other things such as increased obesity and
long lingering health effects associated with
the covid-19 virus participants selected for
our biomedical data science Innovation lab
will leverage these presentations as vital
material for our culminating in-person Grant
project development and workshop to be to be
held at the lodge at St Edwards Park in Seattle
Washington in June 2023. today we have a very
special presentation and I'm delighted to welcome
not one but Forest speakers Julia Roper Autumn
Lerner Darcy sawatski and Jennifer Cho from
the Panorama group based in Seattle Washington
one of the uh of them Julia Roper is one of our
uh bdsil mentors this year we're very excited
to have her and she is a senior program officer
at Panorama strategy a social impact consultancy
where she works with clients ranging from biotech
companies philanthropies and multi-layer multi
excuse me multilateral agencies to advance their
health strategies and especially pertaining to
policy program design advocacy and partnership
she's worked with the World Health Organization
UNICEF and many other uh Global programs
initiatives and institutions Autumn Lerner is a
pandemic Action Network director of communication
and Partnerships and she's an accomplished Global
Communications leader having over 20 years of
experience at the intersection of social impact
program leadership cross-cultural management
integrated campaigns and Community engagement
and she has been involved in in helping to deliver
work across 30 different countries in an extremely
adapted building partners ships and managing
stakeholders and influencing things across markets
in various sectors Darcy sawatski it was named
a 2020 top woman in public relations by the pr
news and Darcy has a 23-year 23 year record track
record of success in health Communications public
and private Partnerships social marketing
campaign development and media relations
um and as vice president of Partnerships
Jennifer Cho leads panorama's collaboration
with philanthropists philanthropic organizations
and strategic Partners on a variety of diverse
opportunities um for impacting uh their work
and the work of others she has more than 20
years of experience in non-profit development um
working with a variety of different organizations
and startup divisions from places such as New
York University and various other organizations
um in continuing with this year's 2022-2023
biomedical data science seminar series theme
today's lecture from Team Panorama is after the
research using policy advocacy and philanthropy
as levers to address the consequences of covet 19.
the Panorama group is a platform for social change
their community of multiple organizations
develop scalable solutions for some of the
world's most pressing challenges today the team
from Panorama will speak about their work to
alleviate secondary health effects of covid-19 by
mobilizing networks of Partners shaping policies
and advocating for resources and systems of
change and the role that data science plays in
achieving those goals as always we are streaming
this lecture live and for recording via YouTube
and if you're watching on YouTube thank you so
much for joining us also our specially selected
2022-2023 biomedical data science Innovation lab
participants and alumni are encouraged to submit
any questions they have via the chat session
the chat feature of their Zoom sessions I will
synthesize these questions and ask them on your
behalf during the last 10 minutes or so of the
lecture and with that welcome team Panorama
we are super excited to hear from you guys
hi Jack thanks for that introduction um and
hello everyone we are excited to be here I'm
going to kick us off and then bring in
my colleagues throughout the next hour
um before we dive in in case you did not pick up
on this already from our bios and want to get the
elephants can identify the elephant in the room
be blunt and get something out of the way from
the beginning which is we are not researchers
and we are not academics and I know that there
can be this Infamous divide between the academics
and the program people I know the academics look
at us and say gosh like they're a bunch of liars
and because we do we misrepresent your data all
the time we don't do it on purpose but we're so
focused on what's the so what what's the spicy
sexy takeaway what's the you know the Twitter the
160 character way to boil down a lot of research
so we do it it's not intentional but I know we're
working on it likewise we look at academics and
we think gosh their PowerPoints are so ugly and
for some reason like we think that's important
and care about that so I know this tension
exists but if you're willing to put it aside
um for the next hour or so are we because
the reality is I know that we need each other
um you all are out there identifying problems
identifying root causes coming up with Solutions
assessing what's working assessing what's
not working um and then we take all of that
and put it in beautiful PowerPoint so really
the role you know we're working together and
and hopefully you'll see that we aim to do a
little more than that which we will talk about
today the work that we're doing in advocacy and
policy change in helping enable implementation
um of new programs and ideas that originate from
data science and research um so today we're are
going to share a little bit about panorama group
and our organization and then we are going to
highlight a couple specific examples of projects
that we do and our Reflections on data science
and what it means for our work so I will kick
us off with an overview on Panorama group um so
Panorama group we are a platform for social change
and what does that mean it means essentially we
don't specialize in one specific topic area
or functional area but rather we specialize
in making change happen doing whatever it takes
the idea being that true social change often comes
by working together working across entities across
sectors across topic areas and no one organization
or functional area can do it alone so what we
do at Panorama is to mobilize change makers to
work together and we aim to equip social movements
with the tools needed to drive impact so as Jack
mentioned we have three different organizations
within the Panorama family Panorama Global which
is a social impact nonprofit Panorama strategy a
social purpose consultancy which is where I sit
and then we have a new entity Panorama action
which is able to log be in pursuit of social
impact goals this next slide shows a sampling
of the many different things that we do and the
different hats that we wear within Panorama
so we provide behind the scenes Operational
Support for emerging non-profits we've run
collaborative funds where multiple donors
can pool resources to support a social cause that
they care about we deploy funds to grantees we've
launched coalitions we've served as secretariats
we provide consulting services and the list can go
on and through that we've worked on a variety of
projects in different topic areas our work stands
both domestic work and Global work the topics
we tackle range from public health gender Equity
climate Justice adolescent mental health and more
and working across all these areas allows us to
take learnings from one issue area and apply them
elsewhere it also gives us exposure and experience
partnering with a range of Partners ranging
from academics philanthropist ngos governments
Etc and through all that we've learned a
lot about what it takes to achieve change
so for the next bit we're gonna kind of Deep
dive and share more about two of our programs
one is the pandemic Action Network we'll hear
from Autumn and Darcy and then Jen will talk to
us about the covid-19 action fund for Africa and
then I'll come back and share some Reflections
on what we've learned from our Consulting
work um so with that autumn over to you
thanks so much Julia um hi everyone uh it's my
pleasure to provide a little bit of context and
introduction on what pandemic Action Network is
and and what we do um and how we translate um Data
Insights Research into actual action and progress
when it comes to pandemic prevention preparedness
and response so I'm going to give a little bit of
context and turn it over to my colleague Darcy and
then wrap it up with a little bit before
we turn it over to John next slide please
so what is pandemic Action Network and what is
our role um essentially early uh in covid the
the DNA for pandemic Action Network started
far before that but a group came together
understanding based on experience from previous
outbreaks namely Ebola in West Africa in 2014 and
2015. that in order to actually create change in
order to accelerate the response to covid and to
ensure that the lessons from the covid-19 pandemic
actually translate into to real change and better
preparedness and Improvement in the future um
that we needed advocacy in the mix so pandemic
Action Network really came together and coalesced
around an advocacy Network to to bring Advocates
into this space to translate recommendations
reports Research into tangible action because
what often happens in a pandemic is there's a
moment of Crisis and and there's a lot of action
around the crisis and then as we're seeing
right now uh people and leaders collectively
move on and there will be a lot of research on
the table a lot of reports a lot of landscape
analyzes pointing to next time we should do this
differently or Lessons Learned but there is a
difference between lessons documented and Lessons
Learned and so pandemic action Network's role is
to really be that connective tissue and translate
the recommendations into real action next slide
oh um it looks like
there we go um so just to put a finer point on it
our mission as a network is to drive Collective
action uh to end the covid crisis for everyone
around the world and ensure that the world is
better prepared to respond to outbreaks when and
where they happen and to prevent the next pandemic
and the way that we do that our theory of
change essentially is that we need a lot of
different folks in the tent in order to tackle
these enormous challenges so we believe that
if we have a diversity of stakeholders working
together that we can create advocacy pressure to
compel political leaders and policy makers to
act that means that the network is incredibly
diverse we are not just a network of ngos or a
network of uh philanthropists funders or private
sector or academian research but we bring all
of those those powers and perspectives to bear
and and do that at a global level at Regional
levels and at National levels next slide please
with that our approach is is really a partner
approach we're actually a pretty small and mighty
team that has grown up since uh we started
this work in April of 2020. we started out
with about 25 Partners around the world we've
now grown to over 350 Partners across sectors
and across regions who are actively participating
and lending the strength of their organizational
leadership their voice their strategy to this
fight to ensure that we're better equipped at
every level to prevent a crisis like covet from
happening again but also ensuring that we're
better prepared in the future of when outbreaks
do occur and then all of that is powered by our
our Tiny But Mighty team which is also spread
out across the globe we now have 18 people in
nine different countries in order to power this
network next slide foreign just gives you an
idea of the vast diversity of our Network this
by all means is not all of our 350 Partners it
would become just illegible at that point but
we're starting to get there even with jamming
all of these logos on a single side but you can
see the diversity of uh those who who make up the
network from the private sector uh businesses
like like 3M Johnson and Johnson we also have
um significant Public Public Health agencies such
as the Africa CDC that are actively involved uh
ngos and Advocates at virtually every level um
that are a part of the network day-to-day backside
and the way that we come together
are through various levers of action
um so we are essentially a policy and advocacy
network but in order to really Drive pointed
policy change when it comes to you may have heard
in the news this week talking about the pandemic
afford or there's a number of international Health
regulations that are up for review and reform
um or issues related to vaccine equity in order
to do that we really have to drive Coalition
building and convenience around specific
moments we also have to actively engage
influencers and key opinion leaders in order
to put pressure on political leaders to act
and all of that is supported by very strategic
Communications and at Key moments campaigns
in order to ensure that these priorities
continue to stay at the top of the the agenda
um this is increasingly more difficult
in the current context next slide
so overall our our strategic program of work at
this point in time it's really evolved but in
the beginning of course we were focused on you
know emergency response to covid and what was
necessary from that perspective we have since
evolved our approaches we're really looking
at pandemic prevention and preparedness and focus
more on ecosystem reforms on ensuring that there's
there's money for all of the things that need to
happen to strengthen Health Systems the proper
governance and accountability is in place and all
of this is supported by a network model we want to
ensure moving forward that we don't have this huge
gap in advocacy when it comes to these critically
important issues but that there's there's
capacity building and that is sustained over time
next slide so just a little bit of context
as we continue the conversation today in
terms of like where we're at on the map and
I've alluded to some of this already but
we're in a very different place than we were
three years ago we're now entering year four
of this pandemic we just marked the third
anniversary of uh the Declaration by who of
kovid as a global Health Emergency so Public
Health Emergency of international concern
um at that time all of our Focus was was on the
pandemic the whole world was watching that's
no longer the case we're in this moment of what
we're calling poly crisis where there are so many
different crises that are that are on the map from
Ukraine to energy crisis debt crisis food crisis
um it is very distracting for political leaders
and and yet all of these things are connected and
compounded by the persistent pandemic um there's
also a real lack of coordinated and dedicated
Global Leadership to these issues pandemics have
really fallen down on the agenda and our role is
to ensure that does not happen um and we're really
a forced to counter this cycle of pandemic fatigue
and and cycle of neglect that really persists
in this space because the work is not done yet
um and if we're not in the mix and not being
relentless about it uh there is really a gap
because we know that health systems are stretched
at basically we're we're at a Breaking Point
around the world so many things have fallen
by the wayside because of the focus on covid
in the pandemic there's stuffy shortages there's
a decrease in routine immunization globally and
there's the need to address those issues well
at the same time ensuring that we're addressing
the persistent pandemic as as we also look
for it in terms of of communications and the
context around all of this we're seeing
the real increase in anti-science and
disinformation rhetoric a lot of distrust of
Public Health authorities um specifically in
the United States we're really seeing a risk of
disinvestment in this area safely when we need
challenges are great um and the work of this
network is incredibly important it needs to be
next slide
all right after that I'm going to turn it over to
Darcy right thank you so much Autumn hi everybody
I'm Darcy from evoke kind which partnered uh with
Panorama back in March of 2020 to co-found the
pandemic Action Network and have the great honor
of staying on as a Communications partner and as
leadership on the behavior change Communications
work group so I get the privilege of talking to
you about the work group but also how we actually
use and talk about data science in this group so
go head on over to the next slide when the when
the the crisis hit when the pandemic hit we really
wanted to pull together folks to talk about what
we could do now to help influence the behaviors
that needed to change to prevent the spread
of covid so we brought these folks together
into a work group our mission was really around
a specific behavior we chose masking as the the
behavior that we could really Drive consensus
and Leadership on um but what that practice
gave us was the structure of a monthly meeting
of bringing these disparate groups together
um as Autumn had said across like Academia
media Communications ngos Public Health
Etc um and be a force a collaborative Force
to make decisions um to share information to
share learnings um to set an agenda of what
needed to be done and figure out is somebody
covering it and can we help that person and now
we are in this wonderful almost sort of routine
of getting back together every month and having
about one to three experts either from within the
work group or invited guests to come share what
they're working on what their research is and
some of these the presentations that stick with
me the most are the ones that are really rooted
in that data science and that are data-driven
solutions for disease prevention so I'm going
to share just a couple of those presentations
with you now but really an open invitation
um to come learn more about what pandemic
Action Network is doing specifically in
the behavior change Communications work
group all right so over to the next one
so one of our partners um that came and gave us
a presentation early on actually came with an
idea not a fun finished product and the idea was
within the United States we were starting already
to see these partisan divides around vaccination
intention um and how could we actually understand
more about what's going on in that space and
then use the best of data to inform a solution
um so even though under the Trump Administration
was the development of the vaccine there was
also sort of an equal measures distrust hesitancy
that was often identity based and so uh we helped
the a coalition of of academics develop actual
messaging and materials for a ad that was aired
on through a purchase on YouTube in specific
pro-trump counties that put the vaccine in the
best possible light and the they did a large-scale
randomized control trial with it to assess whether
this counter stereotypical messaging and partisan
cues could actually induce vaccination and what
they learned and saw in those results was indeed
the counties that were served at this particular
ad showed higher vaccination rates versus
matching counties that did not show the ad
so I know you're all saying okay that's
great I love seeing numbers but I love
seeing ads even more so Julia if
technology will comply is this a
part where you can switch over to the ad
itself and don't forget to share sound
Donald Trump is urging all Americans to
receive the covid-19 vaccine I would I
would recommend it and I would recommend
it to a lot of people that don't want to
get it and a lot of those people voted for
me frankly about Trump and former first
lady Melania Trump did receive their vaccines
privately in January at the White House [Music]
thank you yeah I just love to share that example
um because we we followed the full Arc of that
progress right there was the data to show the
need that we all responded to we helped identify
where some of the potential spokespeople could
be what were some of the uh messages that were
seeming to work with this audience and in fact
it was another presentation from our work group
that had that data about that line your vaccine
is waiting for you that had come from previous
flu research that showed impact that they were
able to use as the call to action at the end and
then of course they had the data to verify and
validate the results of um the the whole entire
project so you'll see the reference at the
bottom if you want to look at the publication
so that was just one example moving now across the
Atlantic Ocean um we were able also to hear from
the UK government on their approach and also how
they use data as a platform to absolutely track
every step of the way where response was happening
to various stimuli in terms of messaging access to
um covet prevention measures whether it be
masking later on vaccination stay at home
Etc and they went through bit by bit with our
work group to go through all the dashboards that
they had established and also how they use the
mechanisms within the UK government to be able
to quickly respond to any sort of miscommunication
misinformation that was out there and ensure that
different stakeholders within the community were
serving as key Messengers um and through the the
measurements that they had they were able to
actually track how many people stayed at home
you'll see in the data here almost 5.9 million 3.6
for million uh social distance as a direct result
of their Communications and then they were able to
model how many infections were presented prevented
and what I think is stunning that they were able
with a certain amount of confidence say that
through these particular strategies between 22 and
27 000 lives were saved which is stunning now this
is not a setting where pandemic Action Network
did this work but through that collaborative and
uh networked approach a much wider range of ngos
non-profits other governments had opportunity to
learn from this and be in touch with these so
that they were able to follow along um and make
sure they had that benefit of that learning
so my final example is a a little bit about
past and future so we've been partnering with the
Mercury project which is um a call for basically
research and projects globally to actually use
data to understand and to come up with data-driven
solutions to improve acceptance of vaccination and
to dispel misinformation and disinformation about
vaccination so they have come and presented to us
a number of times including when they were doing
their first call for a cohort uh for what they
were funding and through pandemic Action Network
and other partners we're able to find projects
all over the globe that are actually tackling this
issue who are currently in the field right now so
at our very next meeting which is on February 16th
we're going to learn from the Mercury project
how that first cohort is going they're going to
present a new framework for research percent they
are using across these projects and they are also
going to announce and this is what I really wanted
to stress for this group a new call for proposals
for the next cohort of projects so as you are
going through this program and thinking what how
can I get involved what would be connected to this
if you have an intervention designed to increase
demand for vaccinations consistent with national
priorities and that could be not just coveted
vaccination but childhood HPV polio measles
Etc this could be an opportunity for additional
funding so you'll see the link there for how to
get more information about that so without further
Ado I'm going to turn it back over to Autumn to
tell us what's next for pandemic Action Network
thanks Darcy um well what's next for pandemic
Action Network is is a much bigger conversation
but one of the things that we wanted to leave you
with is is a little bit of a forward-looking you
know just thought starter in terms of uh potential
areas for research and inquiry and as we look at
addressing secondary side effects of covid-19 I
mean look there are many uh their Public Health
social economic political challenges related
to Long covid mental health education deferred
Healthcare um the real failure of political
leaders to act or disinvest precisely when we need
to invest as I was speaking about earlier the the
growing attitude of anti-science or dismissiveness
there are actually so many side of scenery effects
of covert that we actually don't even know yet
however we wanted to leave you with two thought
starters first is a trend that we're seeing in
terms of growing distrust in immunizations and
this is not limited to covid um although covid-19
um anti-vax attitudes increasing has potentially
impacted what we're seeing across the board
um there was a recent study by the Kaiser Family
Foundation you can see some of the headlines on
the right right here in terms of growing vaccine
hesitancy fueling measles chickenpox Resurgence
in the U.S opposition to school vaccine mandates
um from that recent study it was determined and
it was clear that more than a third of parents
now say that they should have the right to not
vaccinate their children um for measles mumps and
rubella this is an issue based on recent data that
is also clearly partisan uh in terms of 44 percent
of adults who either identify as Republican or
republican leaning saying that they should have
the opportunity and the choice to opt out this is
a jump up from 20 in a pre-pandemic poll this is
very significant and has the potential to really
have an impact on public health and Health Systems
in the United States so that's one area to get you
all thinking another area is is more squarely
in our wheelhouse and if there are areas of
inquiry around this area we really want to talk
to you and this is around the failure to act on
the impact of the pandemic we know that the kova
19 pandemic has basically affected us all in one
way or another some more than others of course
um yeah but it is in the double digits in terms
of uh those who have been personally impacted by
losing a loved one like we we feel these impacts
quite personally and yet the rhetoric at the
political level is disconnected from that reality
um and in recent polls uh from National polls
in advance of the last election the the midterm
elections it actually showed that like covid-19
was like the least priority for people and yet
the priorities politically were around the
economy and inflation all things that are
actually squarely tied to the pandemic and so
we have this disconnect between individual and
personal experience and constituencies and and
political leadership and areas of investment men
in a recent report from the International
Federation of the Red Cross and red present
societies that they defined the pandemic
as the biggest disaster in living memory
um more than any earthquake drought hurricane in
history has claimed as many lives so we're at a
time where we really need political leaders to act
with urgency in response to this crisis but we're
not seeing that and what will it take to actually
move a shifted narrative and a shift in action
um and you know just as a Corollary
when 9 11 happened in the United States there was
a commission in Congress in actual clear actions
and policy changes we're not seeing the same
level of action and on the contrary a lot of
politicization and that's specifically in the US
but we're seeing those Trends across the board so
two areas to consider for future inquiry uh with
that I'll pass it over to my colleague Jennifer
thank you so much Autumn and so as I start I want
to mention briefly that just prior to joining
Panorama I was in university development for
10 years and over that period of time I had the
privilege of supporting Engineers data scientists
and public health professionals so I'm um I have a
deep appreciation for this lab and the work that
you all do um so thrilled to be able to be here
um starting in 2022 I had the privilege of working
on two major Cova game team response projects
uh Grant making initiative fund and supportive
mental health and well-being of hypoc and lgbtq
Adolescence and this project that I'm about to
share with you where we got to go deep on global
health challenges under the age of pandemic Action
Network so as you may be able to guess from this
quote I'm about to have ask you to come back with
me to March 2020. what was starting to happen then
there was a global Scramble for PPE among even the
world's wealthiest countries we discovered that
most of the PPE was being manufactured in just
a small number of areas shipping had slowed down
and here in the U.S and across around the world
routine Healthcare had paused next slide please
so for those of you who are not familiar community
health workers are sometimes called the invisible
kajra but they are the first line of defense of
prevention and treatment for hundreds of millions
of people around the world including here in the
U.S so as the pandemic is starting to happen what
do we know in most countries um where that are
heavily reliant on community health workers as
part of their Health Systems they are not formally
part of the health system so they are not counted
as part of Health worker accounts meaning that we
are not including them in projections for PPE need
I think the thing that we all know very deeply
right now is that Frontline health workers need
PPE to work both for their own safety and so
that they are prevented from becoming vectors
of disease infection themselves so um this
was flagged early on by the community of of
organizations that support Community Health work
the first recorded death from covid-19 in Sierra
Leone was a community health worker the longest
tenured Community Health worker in the country
and then this critical piece of information that
is the last statement on the slide sometimes
during times of Crisis it's this the stoppage
of Essential Health Services it actually leads
to more so all the more reason for attention
next slide please for those of us who work
in global Health there was an obvious solution
someone needed to ensure that community health
workers had PPE and we were going to need
to use private funding to make it happen
um and there was going to need to be a
mechanism to make it happen so next slide
so this life or death challenge brought together
more than 2 20 non-gov governmental organizations
in 18 ministries of Health with five lead
organizations and Julia if you'll click please
um here is where I betray my age um for those of
you who might remember Voltron or the ThunderCats
or the Power Rangers you'll get the idea a group
of organizations a number of which collaborate
regularly and several of which are already members
of pandemic Action Network formed an ad hoc group
to take on key pieces of work in a radically
collaborative way to figure out how to solve
this problem um it helps that several of us
as I mentioned have were collaborating already
and really what informed this is that we've been
working very long term in spaces of advocacy to
understand how does the health system work
what are the challenges and who needs to be
engaged in this effort if we have to create
our own mechanism so next slide what did we
do we created an end-to-end mechanism to make this
happen from needs estimation fundraising sourcing
all the way down to Last Mile and why did we think
this would work we had long-standing relationships
with donors who support community health workers
in disaster relief there's our private funding
we have the ability to move relatively relatively
quickly thanks to relationships with organizations
and ministries of Health we had been doing
ongoing work to ensure that the emergency
effort could potentially influence global Health
financing mechanisms and we were going to take a
pooled procurement approach which meant that this
collection of otherwise of low and middle-income
countries who otherwise would have no way of
competing in the global marketplace with countries
like the U.S could become competitive because
they were sourcing across countries so next
I'm going to start here by highlighting a few
different elements and um I'm very aware that
as we think about this this is small data but
in a small data that sits on top of really big
data as you can imagine but in ways that
is messy and spread out over countries
so what if you think back to what I said earlier
what do you do when there isn't a formal count of
community health workers will you go to the
organizations that support community health
workers and you Source the information that
way so we worked with 20 plus organizations
to pool the information that they had to create
account and that count then enabled us to have
a marker against which we could apply the best
information we had available in April 2020 to
project what the actual need would be in terms
of supply and then if you go to the next slide
what it was going to cost to supply
community health workers for a year
I want to pause here and say 100
million dollars is a lot of money
And yet when you think about 100 million dollars
in terms of 400 million people who rely on these
Services it's not very much and at the same time
we also knew that in trying to do a rapid response
it wasn't very likely that we were going to be
able to raise 100 million dollars but we were
ambitious and it was part of an effort to message
that in the grand scheme of global financing it
wasn't a lot of money to be able to protect the
health workers who are serving 400 million people
if you go to the next slide please
this is where it gets interesting
um we had uh four elements in this process that
were constantly in flux imagine the sliders on
these bars Moving Day by Day the best analogy
that I had to explain this when I was talking
to donors it's like using GPS if you're the kind
of person who's willing to take the recommended
side route it's in constant calculation all the
time so if somebody would tell me on a given day
I need you to be able to tell me how far is my two
million dollars gonna go now I would have to say
well it depends on what Supply we have and with
the shipping and the ability of these countries
to accept the funding or accept the supply we were
constantly calculating to maximize donor dollars
feed and assure quality so from here I want
to highlight a few things on the next slide
from left to right it's very hard to see
this but um bye we got very lucky that we
were under the leadership for this component
of direct relief which is one of the country's
largest humanitarian or relief organizations
they had great relationships so on behalf of
the countries we were working with they were
able to negotiate an incredibly good rate at
a time when the market was at Peak to enable
us to supply countries in sub-Saharan Africa
um they were also managing all of that list of
items in the early stages of this we had to make
sure the supply in a very rapidly changing
environment would be able to meet our own
quality assurance as well as the requirements of
individual countries if you look at the middle
section um again remember that shipping had
slowed down so for the first one and a half
rounds of procurement we benefited from the fact
that the world food program working with some
donors had set it up a free to use of transport
and because we were working at such a large scale
we were able to leverage free flights for
quite a bit of this work meaning that our
donor dollars were going more towards bias and
then in that third oh no even as you think about
um once the sorry even as we were procuring we
were needing to think about whether countries
were even going to be able to accept the supply
so memorandums of understanding needed to be in
place of each country and for some countries
they hadn't ever had to manage Supply at this
scale they didn't always have the technical
capacity or experience to handle it so we had
to do some training in Uganda for example this
was the largest shipment of supplies they had
ever received and we had to break it up into two
pieces in order to enable them to do it and then
um just moving quickly to the next slide how are
we ensuring these get to community health workers
if you've worked in global Health you know that
sometimes this is the hardest The Last Mile I've
highlighted two of the more extreme examples of
ways that we got supplies to community health
workers on the left-hand side these visors went
to a polio campaign in the Democratic Republic of
Congo that we weren't sure was going to happen
but did because the supplies were provided 8
500 community health workers went door to door to
ensure the campaign happened and in the next slide
you'll see we did some pretty intensive tracking
where possible we use the Ministry of Health
Supply chains to do this but otherwise we were
using relying on NGO expertise to get this done
in the next slide our impact so we started our
deliveries in August 2020 and by January of 2022
this is what we had achieved I want to highlight
this was shocking to us in 2020 we were the fifth
largest procurement mechanism for PPE but the most
important thing was Julia if you'll click again
this was the impact we were able
to achieve as much as possible
to prevent a stoppage in routine
health services at the community level
so what did we learn there's
some highlights here um
and one of the things that I really one of the
things that was very exciting for us is that is
this last point where in some instances we
were able to use this as a leverage moment
to finally get community health workers
recognized as part of the health system
most critically for us in the middle and end
stages of this the last thing that we did as part
of this project when we wrapped up in January was
that we took all of the Lessons Learned forward
through pandemic and pandemic Action Network to
provide information to the global Health Community
about gaps that we were anticipating that would
prevent things from moving forward improvements
that could be made um and key areas that needed to
be addressed um we're hoping that this effort in
addition to having a tremendous impact on delivery
of health services will also serve to continue to
reinforce the need for pandemic preparedness
and the inclusion of community health workers
um I'll stop here there's a variety of
different information that we provided
in the slides that were shared with you earlier
and we would be happy to answer any questions
great thanks Jen and to the whole team I'm gonna
spend just five minutes wrapping us up and then
we will do some q a um so as I mentioned at the
beginning I work um a Paramus strategy which is
the Consulting arm of the company we realize that
from all these different programs that we've been
involved in we've learned a lot and we now want
to support other people who are engaging in social
change Ambitions to to share our learnings
and help them enhance their social impact
so let's hear a little bit about us and then
some of our learnings in terms of data science
so our focus is on we help clients with strategy
development strategic Communications stakeholder
engagement and advocacy we partner with a
number of different types of organizations
from William philanthropy to academic institutions
multilaterals government agencies we partner with
pharmaceutical companies and other basically we
are willing to engage with anyone who has the goal
of having social impact um and then what we've
learned through that work is you know the world
has changed so much since coven and things that
we thought we used to know about global Health
about other areas we no longer know we need new
data we need to understand the secondary effects
of covid-19 and how it has touched every other
element of our world um most importantly what
we've learned is that the pathway from evidence
to public health impact is rarely straightforward
um ideally we would you know once we have the
data to understand what is the problem what
are the solutions like that would be it however
in reality that that's typically only step one
instead what we've found is we are constantly
relying on a number of different levers and
going back and forth between them to in order to
reach that impact so for example we're helping
our partners figure out what advocacy is needed
what are the different platforms to disseminate
your message and the advocacy material and what is
the framing and the Strategic messaging that will
resonate with key decision makers we're looking
at you know what is the state of the world right
now what are the topics people care about what
will help politicians get reelected understanding
different people's interests and priorities and
then helping to tell a story in that context
we also realized that often what's required is
policy change and we look across Global Regional
National local policies informal recommendations
from trusted advisors plays a big role as well
um for example in my previous work I worked
in um spent a number of years in Africa
and Asia supporting governments on the vaccine
introductions and we found that when we did field
research a number of countries had a rule that if
they're going to make a policy change they need a
one of their government approved people on the
research team who's doing the field research so
understanding like what does it take for decision
makers to act on the evidence that they have
um also with in terms of changes needed and
solutions to problems with often much bigger
than the one thing that you're trying to
change but there's a surrounding ecosystem
and infrastructure needed to enable that
change so for example sustainable financing
um changes in global Health often has impact on
the health Workforce and the HR needs their supply
chain factors to take into account as Jen spoke to
some systems need to be reconfigured um Behavior
change as Darcy spoke to these themes are all
relevant almost every issue that we're tackling
likewise we um Acro was for change to happen
as we talked about the beginning there's a
role for a lot of different stakeholders to play
so there needs to be strong coordination to move
the group forward towards shared goals there
also needs to be strong leadership and social
movements and then not just funding for the
implementation piece but funding for all this
other work there needs to be funding to you know
prop up the advocacy movement or to take the time
to do the necessary steps to go through policy
change to fund the research to have the answers
um and we spend a lot of time playing between
these webs and bouncing back and forth and making
progress and then having to shift in another
Direction and I am really excited to be joining
those of you who are going to The Innovation lab
in June I'm really excited that I'll be spending
that week with you um and be helping to think
through for the different research projects you're
interested in you know what is the surrounding
policy context what does the advocacy space look
like you know what are non-traditional research
Outlets research funding Outlets to consider so
excited to spend that time with you all um for now
if you just closing kind of high level thoughts
I think um a few key takeaways so I think one is
when designing and conducting research I hope that
you know you see it's important to know what does
come next and what are all the contextual factors
at play and knowing that early can help in the
design and planning around research I also think
it's important to strengthen the collaboration
and communication across that Academic Program
divide I think there's a lot more that we could
you know advance and I think we could work with
a lot of efficiency if we were in better touch
across those communities so those are a couple
of Reflections from us really enjoyed getting to
to spend this time with you and for now we'll open
it turn it back to Jack who will um field any
questions oh thank you so much Julia thank you
Jennifer Darcy and Autumn this was uh really a
fantastic uh presentation from the Panorama team
and you guys have done so much stuff one of the
things which I think was just Dawning on me as you
guys were speaking and it was kind of when autumn
was presenting some of her her comments about you
know really we we witnessed something with the
pandemic that I don't think we've probably not
seen in in My Generation Um up until then and
certainly many of of us have experienced the
same thing was science in real time right science
was happening and it was in this really compressed
time frame and so you know pity poor Anthony fauci
you know kind of taking it on the chin for us all
as we like watch this process go on on where
people didn't really realize what science kind
of involves which is a lot of Wrong Turns a lot of
you know getting new information incorporating it
and changing it and you talked about the loss of
public trust and I was kind of curious about how
Nimble our organizations like yours to be able
to help smooth that process so that people can
like take action but at the same time realize that
stuff's happening changing every day how can your
organizations help with that to educate people
and policy makers about those things Autumn maybe
you can comment on that yeah I'll start and then I
suspect that Darcy has some some thoughts as well
um as a network you know we work through
our partners and so there are different
ways that we've activated particularly around
clarifying message and uh responding to miss
and disinformation um because it is all
around and it has just felt exponential
um and so through our partners um we have been
able to leverage resources when it comes to
key messaging around you know XYZ and setting
the facts straight which has been incredibly
important for the general population audience
particularly early on in the pandemic because
Public Health Communications is quite challenging
again Darcy can do a Ted Talk on this in her sleep
um but there's so many things that we don't know
and when information changes and when when the
information evolves there's a lot of like lack of
understanding of like well last week you said this
and now you're saying this and as a network it
was really important to leverage from across our
Network the best information and resources and
messaging so that we collectively could all be
on the same page and that's important as things
have continued and now that we're squarely on
the the back side of the vaccine era of the
pandemic there's a whole other set of myths
and disinformation and um and there's there's the
tip of this beer but there's the back of the spear
in terms of responding to that the tip of the
spear is really like where people receive their
information but from an advocacy perspective our
network has worked with uh Partners such as uh the
center for countering digital hate which is based
in the UK but works globally to really Advocate to
platforms themselves in terms of how they um they
provide a space for Miss and disinformation to
spread and we thought very early on in covid where
you were seeing all sorts of things and then there
was a tampering down and a very intentionality
of like of not giving the green light to any
conspiracy theory and rumor we're actually seeing
a dangerous backsliding on that now with recent
changes and ownership of different platforms
and whatnot and it and it puts the onus even
more on the platforms and and on our community to
continue to Advocate to to protect folks and and
really ensure that the facts are surfacing in
the media we also have organizations that are
part of our Network that are actually actively
focused on using the latest data and insights
and and guidance to educate the media themselves
and journalists because all of a sudden you had
every journalist in the world became a public
health reporter and they never ever covered
public health and that's quite a challenge and
so there's a media really literacy piece of all
of this I'll stop there and turn it over to Darcy
yeah I just want to say with science and then the
communication of science and health messages it
really is a strength and number situation and one
of the benefits I think that panda a role that
pandemic Action Network could play early on and
continuing on is making sure that all of the key
players who are both in the space of learning but
then also communicating out we're talking to each
other I mean I saw it through multiple phases in
the masking messaging of how we were getting out
because obviously the science that we had in terms
of the benefits of mass as prevention from covid
spread is a question that was constantly evolving
and what kind of mass what level of protection
does it just protect you know if you're the person
who's sick does it protect the people around you
or do you get some measure if you're the healthy
person of protection these were questions that
did not have good answers for a long time but
what we were able to do frankly is through our
various Partners make sure we were asking those
questions and getting the best answers that we
had and then the rest of the network was singing
off the same sheet of paper and then as there was
new information that we were also prompting folks
across the network for for new information and I
have as we were preparing for um we launched uh
World mask week in the summer of 2020 to really
get these Partners on board to be all singing in
concert on this message and I I honestly remember
some conversations with various Folks at CDC and
other places where it was evident that even among
our network not everybody had sort of the latest
and greatest and so to make sure that everybody
was having what is the the the best science at
that moment to be able to sing off of that sheet
of paper and that's particularly as things like
better masks came on the market that were more
readily available that they were less worrying
about um uh not being available for health care
providers we were able to act quickly on that
but I do believe that the next you know we need to
make clear sort of from the outset about Science
Education health education that change will happen
so that we can prepare folks for it that we will
always give the best of what we know now and that
that will be evolved and then they need to come
along with us for that Journey fantastic Jennifer
uh you had really gave a fantastic example of just
a logistical challenge of trying to one figure
out how to get money for something how to then
go and like scale it appropriately and deliver
I mean the logistical challenges were really
evident there and anytime somebody does a Power
Rangers name drop I'd like you got my attention I
wanted to ask you what role could data scientists
help play in helping to make sure that the the
mathematics that went behind the distribution
and the logistics of all that how could that
how could that be brought to bear to help
streamline and make that process more efficient
um so here I'm going to apologize in
advance if I accidentally offend anyone
um and this comes from um having worked with
some having had the privilege of working with
some data scientists I think there's a few things
one when you work at scale with data you have
um at least as I understand it there's some
wonderful opportunity in there for you to see
patterns that are not evident to those of us
who are looking who are working at it day by
day who are inputting just a small set of those
and so there's a little bit of a superpower in
there and helping us understand that you can see
something coming or you see something that is if
we Zoom back out from it what is the opportunity
there there's we're trying to fix small things
in big systems that are complicated is there a
bigger fix that could happen because of that I
think the other thing is that I have um worked
with people who are both very um excited to or
also very opposed to the idea that the kinds of
tools that are needed in the moment when you're
trying to be nimble when you're working with
smaller sets of data when the data is really messy
um sometimes what we call in this at the field
level a tool is so rudimentary to people who
are thinking about really complex data and um
but you also have no idea how huge an impact
a small tool that is easy for you to build
can have I think um we were I mean I'm just
going to admit that we were managing all of this
information when I showed you those slider bars
that was a series of Excel spreadsheets it maybe
didn't need to be more complicated than that but
when we think about planning as that scales when
we think about how those tools translate back to
a community what could be built that is simple to
use that accommodates the data and has the ability
to scale so um if anytime you look at something
you're like well that's so easy maybe think about
being thinking maybe think about I can take a few
minutes and create that and then maybe to learn
something from the data that's going into it and
that's fantastic um I think we're very close to
the end of our time here I wanted to certainly
thank Julia for organizing everybody and thank
Autumn and Darcy and Jennifer for providing kind
of examples of things that are going on with uh
with with the team here and the various things
that Panorama group has going on both in the U.S
and around the world to really help us get our
thoughts together to build the network we need
to be able to know who we can talk to to help make
sure that people are getting the right information
to be able to affect policy to affect change uh
both uh policy wise and behavioral uh we're I was
very excited to hear about the Mercury project
as well and so I look forward to kind of poking
around in there a little bit as well but thank
you for bringing that to our attention and thank
you guys um for for sharing this with us this is
really wonderful work and I'm sure that everybody
is our participants are going to be very excited
to talk to Julia here in June in person to to find
out more details so thank you again and thanks
to everyone who joined us and who's watching